forza per riparare i ragazzi mi sono
ricordato di questo gioco pazzesco che
si chiama happy room che era una vita
che non facevano sociale lo ricordate
praticamente quel gioco dove certo
personaggino e tu devi fargli fare le
cose belle tipo tipo pratico questa
non sparano volevo fare un esempio non
ho imparato niente
credo che come fa a ok
credo che debba non so cosa fanno
stirati a ok ci deve finire
categoricamente sopra se non funziona un
cazzo è comunque tu hai un tot di soldi
da spendere per farli più male possibile
quello fatto poi mettete un sacco di rob
è stato veramente fatto bene è un po la
happy with di chi non ci ha voglia di
premere i tasti sulla tastiera allora
non mi ricordo ma il ricordo dovrebbe
essere sui c'è scritto 14.000 punti che
sono tanti quindi non penso di riuscire
a però dover mai dire mai ragazzi meglio
e mi ricordo che ci sono ecco infatti un
sacco di molle che ti permettono di fare
di andare in giro per la mappa cosa
incredibile piazza ragazzi tutte le
molle in modo tale che se per caso
finisce in mezzo comunque si fa i suoi
salti se li fa eco mettiamola così ok
boys let's go video che succede ma
giusto per curiosità
va bene i pirati piranha sono
incredibili quanto sto facendo
non sto facendo tantissimo però ancora
le armi si devono ben scaldare quindi a
posto
madonna i pirati piranha non fanno così
danno mi ricordavo molto peggio madonna
comunque non è malissimo se devo dire la
verità e rispetto a quella partenza
impresa non sta facendo molto il cannone
quello con la sinistra quello che si sta
facendo veramente niente in realtà penso
che ci debba finire proprio davanti in
faccia e un po complicata la faccenda
però vediamo se riesco in qualche modo
non sia mai che hanno a recupare
attivare cannone ci viene proprio
entrare di fascia come è possibile
eccolo eccolo
un pò la fa un pò ne ha fatte di punti e
pensavo peggio
se scoprendo un'altra volta il brutto è
che non puoi comandare il personaggio
non puoi farti niente no s'è fermato la
pena 5.600 normale ragazzi non male per
essere il primo tentativo vai togli
tutto voglio rifare cannone al plasma e
facciamo le cose fatte bene da cannoni
al plasma e le mettiamo un po cannone
ghiaccio il cannone a ghiaccio mi sa che
serve per rallentare quindi io lo
metterei tipo qua e qua ne ho messo un
pò random giusto per fare danno così a
caso se per caso ne becca una male
perché era più o meno tutte le spine ok
alla spina sue spina giù e spinazzola ok
ragazzi ci siamo non so bene cos'è stato
al laser serve nel mezzo se passano e
mezzo fa danno va bene che tra le 1
resca fa veramente poco danno però lo fa
va bene vediamo
come como non sembra male soprattutto
per il fatto che si frizza e quelli lo
pigliano schiaffi non è male non mi
faccio più di prima faccio più di
pipeart che ci sono poche piattaforme
che ti sbatta chi ha una parte all'altra
non è male come tattica e non è male
5000 punti prima prima volta che ho
fatto prima però mi ricordo più non è
male non sanno ma l'attenzione perfetto
perfetto perfetto 6.000 non è male per
niente 6 mila e shiro non lo so però
attenzione 6300 normale non mi dicono
quanto fatto prima ragazzi pero superare
se mi ha fatto fare 14 mila ragazzi in
potevamo battuto il record del mondo
sostanziava impossibile come ho fatto a
fare 14.000 estro gioco è impossibile
fare così tanto bene non mi ricorda
quanto fatto prima ragazzi ma forse è
record di oggi almeno 6500 non male no e
che avuto storto va bene live a berna
bene 6.600 se mila 600 nel male
chiamiamolo come ricordi oggi e facciamo
un po di cambiamenti su questi non si
scompone qualcosa che faccia ti danno a
il raggio della morte costa veramente
troppo ragazze insomma bene tutto ma è
un costo esagerato
questi non sono male leverei le mine a
caso e gli astri scommettere qualcosa di
più potente proprio una roba che spacchi
tipo lascia che non capisco perché così
così tanto però va bene non si vede
perché lascia costa così tanto la che
tantissimo
ogni botta che da solo 200 punti madonna
adesso ho capito adesso la vita perché
costano intanto ok ok si è scassata ma
va bene
madonna quanto danno madonna che botte
sta prendendo lo zio l'obiettivo ragazzi
e sfruttare al massimo tutta la potenza
che si sa solo che è molto complicato
quello che fate veramente molto
complicato la lama la roma secondo è più
la rottura di palle perché un blocco nel
mezzo se non me la devo togliere prova
bene
ok anche perché non fa neanche troppo
danno video che il nostro voto fatto
molto meno era una roba del genere che
avevo fatto una volta per fare quel
record ma non ne sono completamente
sicuro che queste vanno girate di qua
tutte quante let's go ok è più o meno
così ma giusto per vedere
o che ecco già già così già così
funziona di più c'è ci mette una vita ma
funziona effettivamente di più possiamo
fare è rendere costruito un po smr in
tutto questo diamo il fatto è che dopo
un po esplodono sti affari quindi non
serve più a niente comunque averli è
solo per diminuire il tempo di tutta sta
faccenda perché se no non serve a niente
ma intanto da botte da 30 prove con
questa la tecnica giusta ragazzi non ne
vedo altre ho fatto 2000 di danno ok
però comunque arrivano sui 3000 poi per
andare avanti e sempre un macello cioè è
impossibile avvicinarmi a quel record in
tempo in tempo zero ci mette sempre un
sacco di tempo raga però questa è la
questa è la tattica questa è la tattica
amico dovrei lasciare il video acceso
per tipo tre o quattro giorni però
questa era la tattica che avevo usato
per arrivare a così tanto forse raga non
mi conviene mettere solo lame o cena non
lo so come ti avevo fatto fasto record
proviamo proviamo le scotte madonna che
danno il danno non è male danno non è
male danno non è male
secondo me avevo fatto più prima però va
bene ma non si sono ancora del tutto
passatisti cosa incredibile
ok anche stavolta ho fatto abbastanza
danni forse si sa fare un pochettino mi
colpiscono no non mi colpiscono per
niente peccato dovrei trovare qualcosa
che in qualche modo mi mi devi sempre un
pochettino
dave i file torrent andando avanti così
a 14.000 ci arrivò però ci metto
veramente una vita raga però ci arrivo
nè che non ci arrivo su e sono molto
lungo e ci sono le volte in cui pre
incremento al danno però attenzione
ciò è veramente potevo stare qua la vita
ragazzi so non ho pazienza oggi non
importa ragazzi che hanno la ghiaccio
non ho capito se effettivamente funziona
perché non fa danno ti rallenta e basta
non ha molto senso secondo me prova che
mettiamo dal momento in cui non leva
hanno forse leva un po boh non so non
scappi che vediamo parte il fatto che si
esaurisce in zero secondi e power sta
giocando ad apax legends per a parte
quello più o meno ci dovremmo essere
stato e non posso ancora ottimizzare
mettendo tipo una balestra volendo ok
vediamo
questa è il palo fa parecchio il palo fa
parecchio perché non lo stavo usando
prima cacchio il pallone e va beh
quando non disastro
questa era come veramente forte però non
so perché facevo molti più punti ai
tempi o hanno fissato il gioco e le sto
per fare molti meno punti perché una
volta faceva 10.000 punti come niente
come sta roba
ok
perfetto
ea 6.000 ci siamo arrivati quindi la
combo dell'altra volta più o meno più o
meno ha senso per una volta faceva
comunque 10.000 punti e sa cosa non me
la spiego però
viper ii già comunque per oggi è record
è già per oggi è record non è male è
molto più che record ok dai dai non è a
tre punti dai ma è ridicolo
ma cacchio devo regalato mia ragazzi nel
video 8 senza 8 milano vado avanti
secondo me se la rifaccio prende 8 mila
non so perché secondo me se basta
rifarla dobbiamo fare niente se non
rifarla ragazzi perché è possibile dai
per tre punti di merda
dai non ci voglio credere
basta che prende una combo un po meglio
va bene
dai dai dai questa migliori prima questa
migliori prima ancora prima ancora non è
la tavolo sto sparando a cazzo
attenzione moro 7600 c'è ancora l'arma
di a destra per voi non si incastri
7800 c'è ancora la ma che spara e
purissime buonissimo 8 finale
è andata molto meglio di prima e ho
rifatto uguale honegger
8.182 problemi sia piaciuto ragazzi
queste rap il numer non può che non lo
portavo mi manca l'ho detto perché noi
proviamo a riportando secondo me è molto
carino ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
siamo arrivati 8mila quindi 8 mila mi
piace in un minuto grazie di sky del
canale lasciato commento qua sotto e noi
come sempre ragazzi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video ei ragazzi
[Musica]